bonsoir du député merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous vous êtes infectiologues et
épidémiologistes et président de la
mission donc d'indépendants train sur
l'évaluation de la gestion de la crise
kovy 19 en france grazailles à nous a
présenté un petit peu votre rapport a
tenté voie d'être synthétique parce
qu'il y à beaucoup de choses
j'ai une question qu'est ce qui vous a
le plus surpris ou choquer vous dans
cette gestion de la crise quand vous
avez analysé le cas français écoutez
tout dépend de la manière dont on se
place si on fait une comparaison
internationale
ou bien si on se plonge un team moore
dans ce qui s'est passé en france est ce
qui vous intéresse avant tout évidemment
c'est ce que nous avons pu retirer de
nos entretiens on a fait plus de 200
entretiens on a eu accès à tout le
matériel que nous aurions voulu
consulter
on a réussi à ne pas avoir aucune des
experts aucun doute qu'une des personnes
qui que nous voulions voir qu'ils sont
venus au fond suivre nos interviews dont
donc travaillé dans de magnifiques
conditions
cette mission est très exceptionnel
puisqu'elle a en même temps étudié le
sanitaire l'économique et le social qui
est tout à fait unique ces promos le
premier pays qu'il l'a fait et nous en
avons dû rendre ce rapport
suite au fait que l'organisation
mondiale de l'eau ms demandait que
chaque pays fassent de même et que on
restitue pour l'organisation mondiale de
la santé qui démarre son assemblée
mondiale la semaine prochaine dans ces
conditions là on fait que oui nous nous
sommes penchés sur la situation de près
et pour essayer de comprendre et surtout
pour essayer d'améliorer ce qui pouvait
être amélioré ya une transformation
formidable de la gestion de cette crise
un pays qui est un pays centralisé qui a
su territorialisées et ça ça a été un
aspect extrêmement positif de la de
l'évaluation
si je peux me permettre ans a mis du
temps quand même cette
territorialisation on l'a pas constaté
dans les premiers mois
du virus il a fallu attendre la deuxième
partie de l'année n'est ce pas tout à
fait mais a contrario dans les pays
comme le mien la suisse ou l'allemagne
qui sont des pays
par définition qui travaillent de
manière fédérative donc où chaque canton
où chaque länder travail à sa façon il a
fallu centraliser pour que les actions
soient bonnes dents voyez il n'y a pas
de système et des âmes mais vous avez
raison
cette territorialisation a pris un
certain temps mais aujourd'hui elle est
effective elle fonctionne bien et je
crois que c'est de voir ce changement de
au plan de la gestion est quelque chose
de très important est évidemment notre
message principal votre reportage là
bien là bien dit c'est que l'autre
recommandation première qui est basé sur
une série de recommandations comme vous
l'avez dit nous en avons fait 40 memel
dizaine qui s'adresse à la santé
publique pour une transformation de la
santé publique française qui est
existante mais qui montrent
d'intelligence collective et de travail
en commun de mise en commun des
ressources et des décisions avec
certainement eu un excès souvent
d'administrative à sion je dirais des
décisions mais tout ça c'est quelque
chose qui est certainement connu de
l'organisation en france justement dit
d'éviter cette transformation de la
santé publique est ce que vous avez
constaté dans votre travail immense à
une évolution c'est de cette santé
publique avant le virus est maintenant
est ce qu'il ya eu une amélioration sur
ce plan est indéniablement vous savez
tout les santé publique sont en général
dans tous les pays du monde un peu les
parents pauvres non seulement de la
médecine mais également avec la santé
publique implique aussi les sciences
vétérinaires l'essence de
l'environnement la santé globale en
général mais nous avons vu les
changements blues à vous les avez vu
vous même vous avez vu la capacité des
désintéresse de se transformer en organe
de terrain qui sont proches du terrain
pour comprendre les chaînes de
transmission donc nous avons vu des
changements mais il ya encore 12
tout changement à réaliser en matière
d'épidémiologie de terrain c'est un
terme un tout petit peu barbare mais ça
veut dire simplement de s'approcher
d'expliquer à celles et ceux qui doivent
nécessairement adopter les bonnes
pratiques pour prévenir la transmission
de ce virus
il n'ya pas évidemment que la
vaccination qui est fondamentalement
importante tout le monde l'aura compris
mais également évidemment le respect des
mesures barrières le respect de du test
le respect de la consigne d'isolement
par exemple donc on voit bien des
changements on voit clairement des
changements en france on peut faire
certainement mieux comme d'ailleurs dans
tous les pays du monde il faut bien le
reconnaître par me pardonnez moi
parvenir vos 40 propositions à vous
mettez l'accent sur l'importance de la
recherche française notamment pour les
vaccins cela vous a choqué qu'un
laboratoire comme sanofi hopping pasteur
ne soit pas encore sur le marché
non ça nous a d abord tout d'abord déçu
parce que on connaît la force de sanofi
qui est une des meilleures meilleurs des
meilleurs groupes au monde pour produire
des vaccins en particulier par exemple
contre la grippe je crois que attention
sanofi n'a pas dit son dernier mot il ya
encore un vaccin qui est en préparation
et il est certainement extrêmement
intéressant nous n'avons pas pu faire
une analyse complète de la recherche en
france c'était un tout petit peu en
dehors des marges de la mission est
peut-être que certains vont nous trouver
un peu complaisant dans ce sens là et
nous aurions a dû avoir probablement
encore d'autres entretiens encore une
autre approche pour le faire mais oui à
quelque part il y as certainement la
place pour une forte réflexion sur la
mission de la recherche et de
l'innovation en france mais je laisserai
probablement cette tâche à une prochaine
mission
vous savez tous les pays du monde ont à
faire des progrès et chaque pays devrait
faire cette mission telle qu'elle a été
réalisée en france nous serons
certainement la première démission a
rapporté à l'assemblée mondiale de la
santé lundi prochain on est on espère ne
pas trop de missions sur ce type de
virus en tout de même des
et vous vous dites que tout le monde a
été lent ycompris l' oms
comment expliquer qu'une organisation
mondiale dont c'est quand même voilà le
dessin de s'occuper de deux crises
sanitaires de santé mondiale comment
expliquer qu'elle ait été aussi lente
précisément écoutez c'est un peu
compliqué la gouvernance de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé est
en révision depuis de nombreuses années
en tout cas depuis le temps que je
travaille en collaboration avec cette
organisation ce qui fait plus de 25 ans
et au fond lorsqu'on est en état de
crise et tout le monde l'a vu dans tous
les pays du monde
évidemment c'est comme utiliser un
projecteur qui va signaler au fond
certains des défauts voire même beaucoup
des défauts et ses eaux sont au fond ce
qui s'est passé l'om s est très
dépendante de la volonté des pays est
très et peut-être trop politisé il est
temps certainement de transformer cette
cette organisation mondiale de la santé
qui souffrent vous l'avez eu aussi d'un
budget pratiquement ridicule par rapport
à sa mission et donc il est temps aussi
du côté de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé de fer 7
cette analyse en profondeur cette de
tirer les leçons de cette crise pour
continuer à améliorer le système il ya
des choses qui ont bien marché la
consultation des experts
mais il ya d'autres choses qui ont moins
bien marché dans la rapidité de réponse
que nous avons dit aussi c'est que
l'europe de la santé était totalement
absente au début de la crise c'est
rattraper ensuite mais là aussi il y
aura des progrès à faire
donc il faut être très humble par
rapport à cette situation que personne
n'avait connu auparavant
aucun état aucun cher des cas aucun
ministre de santé dans le monde n'avait
eu à gérer une telle situation
restons humbles mais apprenons
évidemment de la crise pour faire mieux
tout de suite un moyen terme
et puis pour la prochaine fois même si
personne ne l'espère mais elle arrivera
une fois bien entendu dernière petite
question un petit peu poil à gratter
pourquoi avoir demandé un infectiologue
suisse de faire ce rapport pourquoi pas
un français pour votre légendaire
neutralité peut-être il faut le demander
à l'exécutif français je ne peux pas je
ne peux pas répondre à cette question
merci en tout cas didier pittet on était
ravi de vous avoir merci de nous avoir
consacré ces quelques minutes lors de la
remise donc aujourd'hui de votre rapport
merci à vous